Free movement of capital and services
This is the basis of the European Union.
We are absolutely not against it.
We want to live normally
To live normally means to live safely.
To live normally means to be able to decide
What car we want to drive
whether we can enter the city center or not
to live normally it means yy to be able to live in a house for such
what we can afford
not a yy z
in the name of imaginary some climate policy
don't put big money into it
to this house yy renovate
to live normally it is also to be able to eat
our food produced in the European Union
We know what s in this food.
We do not know what is coming to us from Ukraine.
I don't know
What food will come to us from South America
we want to live yy
Poland has the right to decide the future
yy own country
We do not want to live in the European Union.
which will dictate to us
that I do not know
that now we have to
lose our nationality and accept all this
What comes from the European Union
What is valuable Mr.
Editor in the European Union
EE does not necessarily involve ideology
or yy
Excessive influence
EU officials for every aspect of our lives
We want to live normally
We want to be free people in the European Union.
Confederation of Freedom and Independence